Dave Pawnee lost his arm in an
industrial accident two years ago at
home in Doncaster he's grateful to the
NHS for its replacement but misses the
sensation of touch if you could get
feeling it would feel more real so it
wouldn't you'd feel more comfortable in
it obviously you'd probably get more use
out of it it would be nice because
obviously from this there's absolutely
it's just plastic but that could soon
change a team of scientists has created
a system of sensors and a sheet of
electronics that connected together can
for the first time produce a finely
tuned virtual reality sense of touch for
amputees a haptic interface on a robotic
hand could capture the shape and texture
of for example a cup that sensation
would be reproduced on the upper arm by
the virtual reality device attached in
the skin the technology could also lead
to a whole new dimension in video calls
with users experiencing virtual reality
touch the technology uses a lightweight
sheet of electronics in a soft laminate
placed on the skin mechanical components
vibrate to create the sense of touch
globally the virtual reality market is
estimated to be worth 13 billion pounds
this year but is forecast to grow to 10
times that by 2023 the team behind this
invention sees it as just the start it
really forces you to kind of reformulate
electronics to be more biocompatible or
skin compatible so the key unique
features of the technology or that sort
of soft skin compatible form factor the
very tiny miniaturized force actuator
that we that we've been able to develop
the growing use of virtual reality in
industry and medicine to manufacturing
and entertainment has until now relied
primarily on sight and sound
but potential for a high-quality sense
of virtual reality touch would be a
game-changer
Jarett up sky news